in a few hours time man Wong's you will
find out whether she'll be extradited to
the United States or set free
Canada's arrest of one of the
highest-ranking executives at Huawei has
placed the country in the middle of a
complicated dispute between the US and
China I can assure everyone that we are
a country of an independent judiciary
and the appropriate authorities took the
decisions in this case without any
political involvement or interference as
must be the case but political
involvement from Washington is exactly
what many in China suspect is behind
Ming's arrests China's economy is
becoming stronger and I think the United
States is unhappy about that so they've
done something to harm China's interest
I think makes the rest could be related
to that Meng was reportedly arrested on
the same day that Chinese leader Xi
Jinping dined with US President Donald
Trump at last weekend's g20 summit in
Argentina that meeting resulted in the
announcement of a 90 day truth in their
trade dispute it now appears to be on
shaky a grand than ever for more on this
let's bring in Gabriela Maya he's the
director of the Evo Center for
international economics he joins me from
Munich welcome to the program Gabriele
looks like the economic truce between
Washington and Beijing is over before it
really started yeah looks like it
of course we don't know what will happen
today and we also have seen yesterday
that the Chinese leadership is trying to
a comet so very nervous yesterday so
let's hope that something survives from
the steak house truce a week ago hmm
now China says mrs. Wang's arrest is an
attempt to curb who are wise rapid
expansion is that plausible that is
plausible and we need to understand that
why is the symbol of the technological
catch-up of China it is a firm that
matters for new technologies for 5g for
telecom infrastructures it is also the
best hope for the Chinese
to develop a own chip industry which
they still do not have and which makes
them dependent from us supplies so in a
way he ye is at the center of this
technological struggle for supremacy
between Washington and Beijing so would
it be fair to say that this dispute that
we're seeing between the US and China
may be less about trade but rather more
about technological leadership I would
say so yes we hear a lot about the trade
balance of course and it is true it's
negative and massively negative but it's
also true that the United States and
China fight about about new technologies
and we will see more of that for the
decades coming this is probably a
struggle that will define the next
decades and the episode we're living
through today just that tells us how
important that is on both sides the
trade story to that is only one part
what we're talking about you know the
role of the leader of the world of
tomorrow and that battle is going on so
will will be very interesting to it very
interesting to watch what's going on my
Gabriel many countries see who our way
and it's ignore technology with a lot of
skepticism rightfully so yes there are
two issues I think one is the the
accusation that the rise of a way is
based on unfair practices of
infringement of copyright and trademark
and patent rights that's one thing
there's some evidence to that even if I
think the United States are sometimes
exaggerating the case and the other
thing is that there's a lack of
transparency we don't know really the
involvement of the Chinese state in
Hawaii since well why is supplying the
world with critical technologies there
is an issue if the Chinese state is very
very present in the firm again there are
I think legitimate worries about the
state involvement in that firm and that
has an impact on security concerns not
only United States but also in Europe
Gabriella Ferber Maya director of the
Evo Center for International Economics
thank you very much